dans cette guerre il y a des noms de
villes qui font frémir comme tchernihiv
vers laquelle roule ses chauffeurs
des groupes électrogènes de l'essence
les communications fonctionnent alors
une dernière prière avant la route on va
revenir tous ensemble et vivant n'est ce
pas
oui tous ensemble
une route rétréci par les arbres coupés
en guise de barrage
nous parvenons à joindre un français qui
vit encore à tchernihiv
le convoi quitte la route 40 minutes à
travers champs le chauffeur est nerveux
les colonnes de fumée annonce la ville
je regarde de partout les obus peuvent
tomber de chaque côté
nous circulons entre les chars ukrainien
et nous longeons les positions russes
à cette église nous y sommes nous sommes
à chinese le convoi va rester une heure
seulement dans la ville nous avons donc
une heure pour travailler christian
mathieu skis le français que nous avons
eu au téléphone et là il nous attend ma
maison à moi était partiellement
bombardé et donc si vous voulez on
conserve on conserve nos vêtements les
produits de première nécessité dans la
voiture quoi
tchernihiv et sa ville depuis 20 ans il
a à coeur de nous la raconter ses 55 ans
est pratiquement un tiers de ma vie que
j'ai passé en ukraine il parle il parle
sans arrêt et nous montre là où les
missiles russes sont tombés
aujourd'hui apparemment c'est
relativement calme
apparemment pas d'aviation mais ça peut
changer ça change de minute en minute on
n'y a jamais rien d'établi il y a trois
jours un obus a fait 10 morts dans la
file d'attenté d'une boulangerie
kristian matte où c'est ce qui nous
emmène à l'hôpital qui a besoin de tous
dans les couloirs les fils des
générateurs qui fournissent de
l'électricité
nous rencontrons natacha est là une
urgence
nous montrer ses caves
ou des dizaines de personnes s'abrite
chaque nuit
les visages blanchâtre qui ne voient pas
le jour
des enfants épuisés
n'est pas un endroit pour vivre ça fait
vingt-cinq jours qu'on est là on est là
depuis le début
leur à passer le convoi sortira de la
vie d'une centaine d'habitants mais tous
ne partent pas
vous n'êtes pas sur la liste non j'y
suis en bas je suis pas sur la liste
restée partir le dilemme de la guerre le
mwh à partir d'ici pour moi c'est très
difficile
c'est pas qu'est ce que le faire ils
vont pas nous ne devons pas nous
exécuter non plus hein c'est pas on
verra bien
déchirant départ
et comme promis dans la prière ils sont
rentrés à kiev vivant et tous ensemble